what's up guys welcome to an episode of
ij likes now this is going to be a
special one and it's dedicated to
breaking bad so pretty much everything
i'm about to talk about it has to do in
some way with breaking bad there will be
no spoilers if you've never seen it
you guys know the finale was this
weekend and
i'm on the west coast so the east coast
sometimes there's these like really
shady streams that you can get so i
ended up watching one of those i'm like
sitting on my computer just freaking out
because every time the stream would drop
i'd be like
i'd miss some critical part of the
episode but i couldn't wait until nine
o'clock because i wanted to just see it
i wanted to see it i couldn't i just
couldn't wait to be honest with you the
finale was amazing and i'm so glad that
they tied up every little thing that the
audience wanted to have tied up so let
me know what you guys think in the
comments below if you watched it if you
didn't watch it
well then we have nothing to talk about
but i did see on amazon they're doing
pre-orders for the entire set season and
it's in like this cute little barrel i
was gonna buy one for myself but i
decided that i've seen them all so i'd
rather buy one for you guys so i'm gonna
do a giveaway i just don't know how that
giveaway is gonna happen so stay tuned
towards the end of the video which will
give me enough time to figure out how
i'm gonna do the giveaway first step on
ig likes is some amazing breaking bad
videos that have been my absolute
favorites this first one is the breaking
bad middle school musical by rhettling
want to take my life savings and buy an
rv and make candy in the desert sounds
like an awesome decision
along the lines of musical numbers this
is a taylor swift parody of we are never
ever ever getting back together
ever
gonna cook together we
are never ever ever
they did such a good job including
pretty much every character from the
show into this music video and just
so many inside jokes so props to you
guys this was just absolutely amazing
this next one speechless it's every
little instance where jesse pinkman gets
injured or hurt or
something terrible happens to him
this video is a must watch it's an
interview with the woman who owns the
actual house that the entire show pretty
much takes place in at walter white's
house in albuquerque this is her house
she lives here it is her home you're
kind of a fan of the the big fan of the
show oh yeah and it's been
it's really been a hell of an experience
and having all these people here and
meeting people from all over the world
next up in gaming and tech the only
thing that has been trending on twitter
other than breaking bad is gta now
finally this week grand theft auto
online launches and they've already
released a statement saying don't plan
on actually being able to get onto our
servers because they're probably gonna
fail to make sense considering this game
made over a billion dollars in three
days that's so much money make sure you
guys check out a bunch of my gta videos
on my gaming channel
youtube.comgaming also this past week
taco bell announced they're doing a
promotion with playstation 4. they're
giving away a playstation 4 every 15
minutes you guys do the math because i
don't really i'm
not gonna do it for you i got a chance
to go up and visit the taco bell
headquarters where we went to their test
kitchen and they gave us so much food it
was kind of overwhelming for whatever
reason you missed breakfast and you were
thinking about lunch this is what you do
to get your breakfast and your lunch at
the same exact time
good luck to anybody who enters to win
the playstation 4. i think all you have
to do is go to taco bell and buy one of
the big box meals and you're entered i
love taco bell my god i can go for a
quesadilla right now this week on ij's
book club i downloaded dexter's final
cut by jeff lindsey i don't know how i'm
going to be able to handle all of my
favorite tv shows ending as always if
you guys want to get your free book you
can go to
audible.com link is in the description
for those of you who just like to click
let me know what book you guys download
and also leave me some suggestions on
what i should download next week if i
pick your suggestion i'll give you a
little comment here or something
this episode would not be complete
without a fashion and style segment but
this fashion and style is brought to you
obviously by breaking bad i found all of
these amazing
t-shirts this website had over 95
breaking bad t-shirts and every single
one of them was just
i'm speechless
now the t-shirts weren't enough we've
also got some breaking bad jewelry
thank you guys for hanging out with me
and this aj likes breaking bad episode i
have finally decided what to do for the
giveaway i'm going to post this video on
facebook so all you have to do is go to
facebook like my page like the status
that this video was on and leave me a
comment and i'll let you guys know on
facebook who wins this amazing breaking
bad full dvd set i mean it's so awesome
like this that's it guys i'll see you
later bye
you